[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
happy happy Thursday everyone
I'm sorry that I was out yesterday but
if you could see how silky smooth my
back is right now you'd understand
FYI my waxer has started a GoFundMe to
cover her therapy bills
get well soon Tatiana
it's a good day to mark your calendar
because we may have found an honest
politician Jeff Jackson a North Carolina
Democrat and freshman rep I'm sorry uh
fresh person rep looked into a camera
and said something we've all suspected
but couldn't prove that his colleagues
are a bunch of phonies who don't believe
a word of Their Own
well it was nice knowing you Jeff say
hello to Hillary before your Jeffrey
Epstein
okay I'm still brand new to Congress
I've only been there 100 days and I
don't know if I'm not supposed to say
this out loud but it's true and
important and if you don't know this you
need to it's really clear from working
there for just a few months that most of
the really angry voices in Congress are
totally Faking It these people who have
built their brands around being
perpetually outraged it's an act really
Jeff wow you must be the next Columbo
thanks for connecting the dots for us
all this time I thought politicians were
as legit as John fetterman's recovery
the congressman continued
I've been in committee meetings that are
open to the press and committee meetings
that are closed the same people who act
like maniacs during the open meetings
are suddenly calm and rational during
the closed ones why because aren't any
cameras in the closed meetings so their
incentives are different what I've seen
is that members of Congress are
surrounded by negative incentives there
are rewards for bad behavior amazing
that's I gotta say that's as refreshing
as sitting on a frozen Peppermint Patty
it's great for hemorrhoids why do you
keep looking at me I don't know
I haven't seen you in a year and a half
but yes that's called performance art
Jeff and it comes courtesy of the I word
that he used incentives the more you act
up the more you end up on TV I wonder if
we can find any examples of this
look at the data you're not looking at
any data you're carrying the water for
the gun lobby
have you
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to
it looks like that workshop with Justice
Millet really paid off
course if there were no cameras there
would be no drama and Bowman wouldn't be
vying for that Oscar which is why I
think cameras should only be banned
except in certain places like the
changing rooms at h m and Bill hemmer's
bedroom
but this crap happens all the time
remember these performance artists
you get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they're not welcome that is not
right that is not fair and that is what
we are fighting as well Kavanaugh you
have released the Whirlwind and you will
pay the price don't tell me this is
about consistency don't tell me that
this is about an abdicate a condemnation
of anti-semitic remarks don't tell me
because I didn't get a Single A Time Has
expiring my life would threatened thank
you talk about drama
if you hammed it up anymore Brett
stelter might put you in a hoagie
[Laughter]
of course you can't forget the patron
saint of fake outrage take it away sis
is now president of the United States
[Music]
you know
she's amazing and I'm always wondering I
bet you are too where is she now
wow she's still screaming
of course it's not just the Dems right
Adam I never expected a day to be quite
as emotional for me as it has been
but you guys won
you guys help
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
you know he looks like he's choking on a
hamster
but on both ends
[Music]
they're disgusted I know but it's like
the observer effect in quantum physics
observing a system has an effect on that
system for example I know you're
watching me right now which is the only
reason I bathed but at least for me it's
a hygiene matter for these idiots it's
only about amplifying anger to keep us
divided
the big thing that modern media and
modern politicians have earned is that
if they can keep you angry they'll hold
your attention and they both want your
attention so if you're a politician and
you show certain media Outlets that you
can help them Keep Their audience angry
they'll give you Their audience and
because so many politicians are willing
to play that game now they're in
competition with each other to see how
fake angry they can be they should have
awards for this call them the golden
globalists
huh
all right yeah
shut up
[Laughter]
and who could forget his amazing
transition from 2016 to now here are two
clips of the same guy before and after
discovering the joy of fakery
I'm Justin J Pearson and I'm running for
president of BSG I want to bring
together different voices dissenting
voices voices that may be more liberal
or more conservative in order that we
can reach a point of sort of the radical
middle sign for the lgbtq community
fighting for those who are single
mothers fighting for those who are
ostracized fighting for those pushed to
the river my My Savior my black Jesus
foreign
they should investigate who put Rogaine
in the Memphis water supply
transition would make Caitlyn Jenner
switch doctors
why do you do that well it's
incentivized this week it was announced
that President Biden instead of meeting
victims families of the Nashville
shooting will meet with the state reps
who protested inside the Tennessee
Capitol the lesson if only those
families had hired acting coaches of
course it's easy to blame politicians
for this Behavior which is why I do
blame this on them but we share some of
the responsibility to as well we we
meaning the people who are paid to react
to the news and the people who consume
the news we claim we want more people
like Jeff Jackson but we also cheer when
someone from our team dunks on someone
from their team which isn't often
because most Republicans are white
I mean it's not like we don't mind when
politics starts looking like the WWE but
I don't really want to see Adam Schiff
wearing a singlet
maybe I do fact is the left are the
experts at this crap and they don't stop
they incentivize infantile outbursts in
college by rewarding activists with
descriptions of Bravery just like what
at San Francisco State did to the Mob
who attacked Riley Gaines they were
lauded instead of lampooned and
Republicans can barely keep up with the
drama because they're so often the
target so what's the ultimate
consequence here well this mob violence
mob rule but now it's sanctioned as
protest and its courtesy of Amplified
phony outrage after years of saying the
country is racist white people are
racist cops are races roads are racist
you end up with mob violence redefined
as mostly peaceful protest and
businesses are now racist for not
wanting to get looted so because nothing
is good everything bad is permitted and
now we're seeing it's paralyzed the
country one that's unable to respond to
its own implosion so congrats to Jeff
Jackson who's pulled back the curtain on
this political theater but I guess we
always knew it just today we're paying
the price
[Applause]
welcome tonight's gas he's so tough he
puts gunpowder on his Cheerios host of
Hollywood weapons on the Outdoor Channel
Terry Shepherd
foreign
because clubs usually cancel him Fox
News contributor Tom salou
this director of communications gives
the media palpitations com's director
for Never Back Down pack Aaron perini
soon she'll likely be on the New York
Times bestseller list and also the
no-fly list Fox News contributor captive
Terry let's get the weirdness out of the
way you've been gone for a year and a
half Where Have You Been were you in
jail in some foreign country what did
you do
there's been a lot going on I want to
kill Jeffrey Epstein let me finish
so the place looks great yeah I mean
like it's there's actual Miniatures and
I I want to check this out later you're
welcome because I've again you've built
your career on the back of me but it's
been a while since I've been here yeah
you know I'm a pretty accomplished
d-list cable celebrity in my own right
right but a lot of people it's not funny
it's true I know and the thing is a lot
of people recognize me from this show
and they're like everybody's like oh
it's so great they're oh tat she's so
funny I go yeah cat cat's funny till she
tries to stab you after a two-day Coke
binge which we went through it was rough
and they're always like oh you're gonna
act like this didn't happen I think
you're thinking of someone else
a lot of girls are wearing the glasses
now but I started no ma'am I know who
I'm talking about and they're always
like oh Greg gutfield he's great I go
first of all Greg gutfeld's not real he
is a remote operated ventriloquist dummy
voiced ironically by the guest sitting
next to me Tom Schiller
I do it people I have to break it to you
this is what's going on in the gut-feld
exclamation point show uh what does want
to talk about no you burned your time
you can no longer you can no longer
comment on the topic at hand okay
because poor Tom is sitting there with a
brilliant idea go Tom
do you agree with this guy no well first
of all yes I kind of agree with this guy
but he's a phony himself you know uh
sincerity is its own form of phoniness
now and he's got his T-shirt on he's
like my name's Jeff and I have a Mr
Coffee behind me and I just think that
it's it's terrible that people are
overreacting but I'm reading a script
that I wrote on a with a sharpie but I
really cut the video up because I wanted
to get it right you see how many yeah
yeah jump cuts for a minute this guy is
such a planned Mr Rogers act and he is
he is LARPing as well can I use that
word of course yes absolutely he is uh
everybody is playing their their game
and it's they made fun of trump they
said oh he's a former reality star their
current reality stars all of them and I
used to and it's not just Democrats
there was a republican named Peter Meyer
and I used to love watching his videos
during the pandemic he's out now they
voted him out because he stunk but uh
he he would come out of Congress and he
would go down the steps yeah he'd be
talking to his phone this is Peter Meyer
I'm taking my mask off and I just want
to let you know that I I'm just updating
my constituents and like he acts like
he's got to update us on the stairs it's
all fake they all think they're in a TV
show and they're boring that's a great
point you know what's interesting he
brought uh uh Tommy brought up uh um
Trump
the people giving Trump crap for being a
reality TV host but the fact is he he
was never dramatic he was just rude I
mean he he said what he wanted but he
never raised his voice you never saw him
got he never overplayed who he was as
opposed to Democrat who would often
accuse him of that I think that's right
and I think with Democrats what you
generally see is a an outrage Factory
because anger is a really strong emotion
for voters if you get a voter angry
you're going to get him to show up but
what they the way they act in the
capital on the house floor it's right
there none of them are like that but
they all are acting like they're
auditioning for the Real Housewives of
Washington D.C at any given moment
instead of actually being serious and
doing the jobs they were elected to do
the country's facing big issues right
now and they're all in hysterics on the
house floor acting like and screaming at
each other I tell you that one clip
where the guys are yelling at each other
Thomas Massey and the other rep the
guy's yelling in his face that's where
reporters stand all of the time that is
pure theatrics by that Democrat he was
doing it because he knew all the
reporters would walk up with their phone
and get his his face and that would be
his golden moment and instead he just
looks like a fool get serious and do
your job reporters are such
lemmings
they're terrible you know exactly you
know exactly how to how to catch a
reporter any any it's just too easy you
could say something do anything I don't
know you know cat you know what used to
drive me crazy people on Twitter would
go yes I am literally shaking as I write
this it's like could something happened
on on Fox or somebody said something I'm
literally shaking could that be where
this a lot of this has started from the
the getting the people saw themselves
getting attention for this kind of
behavior on social media yeah and it's
it is extremely performative and
unfortunately it's not just politicians
I write about it in my book
um
and sold enough copies there are never
I'm trying to change the world here baby
I'm just getting started
um so there's a huge gap in what people
actually believe and what they actually
say on so many issues so we've created
all of the wrong rules for our society
and it's great for him to say that I
wish that more people would but that was
sort of a performance in itself but
still it's better than what most
politicians do
um but I don't know Kissinger there was
a lot of blood that was shed on January
6th yes my January 6th
out of my butt yeah um
but I'm so glad I can say that because
I've had to watch that video so many
times yeah I'm like you have no idea how
bad a January 6 can get buddy that is
what you call an amazing tease for her
book because everything she said is true
yes and it's all in chapter five yes
for the audience so the chapter is
called yeah
do you read that Tom I I haven't read it
yet but I'm I'm I can't wait
you definitely you uh
you have my attention
you have my attention all right Popeye
I'm a joke
I'm gonna kill him
I always wanted to say you've been
waiting to say that happened
exactly
yeah it seems Popeye hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else